Scarlett O'Hara lived on a plantation in Georgia, called Tara.
She met Rhett Butler, a dashing adventurer.
The Civil War began.
Scarlett married Charles Hamilton, hoping to hurt a man she once loved.
Charles went to war and died of measles.
She had his son and named him Wade.
They moved to Atlanta to live with Charles' sister Melanie.
Scarlett saw Rhett a lot and they developed a stormy relationship.
Melanie's husband Ashley was captured in the war.
Melanie was pregnant and Scarlett agreed to help her.
Rhett helped Scarlett, Melanie and her baby, Beau, escape.
He left them to join the Confederate army.
The war ended and Scarlett rebuilt Tara.
Scarlett married Frank and they had a baby girl, Ella.
She borrowed money from Rhett and bought a sawmill.
Frank was killed by the Ku Klux Klan.
Scarlett married Rhett after all and they moved to Atlanta.
They had a daughter named Bonnie.
Scarlett and Rhett's marriage began happily,...
...but Rhett became increasingly bitter and indifferent toward her.
Their marriage began to fall apart.
During that time, Bonnie was killed when she fell off of a horse.
Scarlett tried to save their marriage but Rhett left her.
She ended up moving back to Tara.